p
[Music]
[Applause]
he's the Hall of Famer Big Time TV star
Good Morning America and uh has the Mike
Michael Strahan apparel available at the
Men's Warehouse Nationwide and he's got
a new skin and shave line Michael
Strahan daily defense joining us on the
program Mogul Michael Strahan is that
hey is that your office there Good
Morning America
no no no I'm at home right now man I you
know I left work I'm here this is my
home office but hey good to see you man
and that was pretty funny it'd be more
entertaining to watch me watch that game
then watch that game that was a pretty
that was pretty good he might be right
what is in your office that I would find
interesting first thing I would notice
is what I on books a lot of books that
I've never read on the show
but it looks like you've read those so
those are just for for uh decorations
and the thing is that one about here is
slanted the neither like they're not
like all the width it's like different
width so it looks like they just
randomly put there like they've been
read and put back these books have dust
okay we had uh Ross Tucker on he played
in the NFL for a few teams but Ross said
he missed the violence
of the game like you can't hit anybody
anymore do you how much do you miss
violence
um I called it controlled aggression
more than violence I I miss it yes
absolutely I don't miss like randomly
just hitting people I don't even go to
jail for that now I I miss like having a
plan and looking at a 300 something
pound guy and basically knowing that I
am going to continue to beat you down
until you submit to what I want and that
is to get to your quarterback or to make
a run on that play on the running back
that I do miss that that's the only part
but after I watch the guys get hit one
time now after when I watch a game I'm
like I'm good I don't need to do that no
more because if you watch a game and
I've said to my audience if you watch a
game from the sidelines
you would never let your kids play
football oh absolutely not
just the sound of it is
is scary to do that with friends though
I'd have friends come to the game and I
was like you know what just stay down
here on the field and and and I would
talk to him on the bench and stuff and
then I go grab myself I'll be right back
for defense grab my helmet around out
there and come back and their eyes would
be like this because I pick up the
conversation right where I left off and
then you're like because you don't
realize how big and fast and how violent
these collisions are until you're right
up close and then I I tell my friends
too if they're coming towards you over
here don't stand there and then think
once they get closer I'll figure it out
no no no no it's like an object's a lot
closer but these objects are a lot
closer a lot faster than they appear
what was your welcome to the NFL moment
good or bad
oh man well there were several one we
went to the play the 49ers my rookie
year I wasn't even playing I was on the
sideline and I remember there's like
Jerry Rice Steve Young Ricky Water those
guys running out of the um uh um the
locker room
and I wanted to get an autograph I
didn't want to play
and then on my first time with the giant
like my my I was with the Giants and the
first time the Vets came in for a
physical and Lawrence Taylor came in and
that was the greatest player of all time
in my mind the guy love and adored the
most and he walks in he didn't walk man
he was on a conveyor belt he just like
just stood there he just slid across the
road like the Old Spice man
it was amazing and that was that was a
come to moment to come to like okay I'm
a pro and then watching guys who walked
in who were so jacked so big playing my
position and I'm thinking if I gotta
look like that
I ain't gonna laugh here I would never
look like that but somehow I did it man
somehow but you're you're probably
medium sized for the position you play
yeah right it wasn't too big
but I you know I went through different
phases when I was a rookie I came in at
like 250 something in the combine or
whatever then they're like you got to
gain weight but back then they didn't
tell you like you eat proteins and eat
healthy and do this I'm not I'm just
eating fast food and pizzas like I
gained weight until I was like an
engorged tick I was like 280. I couldn't
even move out there and then they're
talking about performance what
performance biggest performance you're
getting out of me is watching me eat so
I ended up losing weight getting the
270s for years and 260 for years been my
last three years that was 247 to 252
every Friday weigh-in which made like I
had three different careers and the last
part getting down to that that lower
weight it helped me keep up with OC and
Justin Tuck and those guys because at
that point I'm 33 to 36 years old going
through those three years and I gave me
a new lease on life felt completely
different as a player more Mobile faster
it could just run all day long when it
comes to assessing these Edge rushers
now like who gets into the Hall of Fame
I hate that edge rushers you're a
defensive end I know I know as Russian
stuff bothers me oh they put him in he's
the edge rusher no if you're a football
player you play everything I love
playing to run more than I love rushing
the pastor rushing the pastor just
another part of the job that I had to do
that I was successful at but I took
pride in doing everything so I would be
insulted if somebody called me an edge
rusher I would be mad because you're
one-dimensional yeah yeah and and I just
wouldn't I never I I took more pride in
in like beating a 300 something pound
guy against the Run play or defeating a
double team on a run play and making a
tackle then it was beating the guy
one-on-one for a sack I mean that was
the glory when everybody sees you out in
the opening the fans cheer but it was
nothing like of playing the run to me
but what's the number now with sax
because it used to be like you got to
100 sacks now you got everybody's
attention now you have more
opportunities to get sex because they're
throwing the ball more so what what
would be how are we supposed to assess
sac leaders or Hall of Fame credentials
for defensive players oh man that's
that's a good one that's really a good
one um I I think obviously the numbers
don't lie you still have to look at
sacks I do think you have to look at the
era in which the player played also and
and what the systems were at that point
um uh you know watching Von Miller last
night I'm like okay he's the Hall of
Famer I I the guy's just an incredible
player but but I think certain guys
would make an impact outside of just
their sacks it's just overall he is one
of those guys I I think when you I think
a lot of things have to change I mean
they added more games now I mean a full
receiving records quarterback records
sack records like everything is kind of
kind of changed and evolved and
I don't know how you judge credentials
half the time did the 200 sacks now only
person to have that is Bruce Smith and I
also and won another one of my favorite
players and a good friend who I deem to
be insane for playing long enough to get
200.
well who knows how many sacks Deacon
Jones really have beacon beacon told me
he had
30 of 40 some 40 something sacks in one
season I swear to God because Deacon
told me had over 40 sacks in one season
and he was serious of the heart attack
he was not joking
and and that's back when you were
throwing 17 to 20 times a game you know
exactly you were running the football
he's out there head slapping everybody
do you hold a grudge
with anybody in retirement
um are you mad at anybody still you know
the crazy thing is I I am not there are
a few guys that I'm like yeah I never
really like you like who and who like
who yeah I mean I probably the one guy
who sticks out my mind is I think John
Jansen
play for the rest of the tackle I never
cared for him for some reason there's
something about him that bugged me
um other than that like John Runyon was
a big nemesis
but I always respected John and he oh he
made me better Eric Williams with the
cowboy was the meanest guy I ever played
again but he made me better what do you
mean medium for that how didn't
everybody mean no not like Eric Williams
it's a different type of thing there's
mean and then there's um you know
terrifying and it's funny because
Michael Irvin said to me yeah you know
every time we used to play you guys I'd
be like yo big fella don't be scared you
better be ready you got a straight hand
because he was like Eric would be like
nervous and I was like I wish I knew
that because I was scared of hell too
but mean Dan is like all right they
throw the ball down the field I'm a
lineman they throw the ball 30 yards
what do you naturally do you turn and
you look at that point I'm a spectator
what does he do
clubs you in the back of the head
punches you in the back like come on man
come on have you ever seen Reggie you
remember Reggie White with with a
preacher of course
who's the only player consistently every
time they play Reggie White won a fight
Eric Williams you got the preacher
wanting to fight
you mean I think God was on Reggie's
side
yeah yeah well well Eric had the devil
on him
[Laughter]
uh he's the Hall of Famer Michael
Strahan NFL on Fox and of course Good
Morning America co-host what was harder
though playing football or being a TV
host on a show you know GMA that's you
know not sports related well I I think
well totally different but I of course
football is harder in every sense of the
word when you have to physically get out
there and bang your body around and not
even the games again I mean you grew up
you grew up getting ready for that you
don't grow up getting ready
in your high school football so I'm kind
of late to the game so for me it was
kind of always interested and I always
loved it
I didn't know any better but the like
the physical part of it was tough
mentally it was tough on training camp
days when you have two a days and you
got to put those paths twice a day and
run into the same teammate and you get
into the pad you get to the the
equipment room in the morning and you
put on those paths and they're still wet
from the sweat from the day before it's
cold and you're like I got a stretch on
this ground with Dew on it and get my
pants wet like oh I I so many days I
quit in my mind but GMA is tough in a
sense because it challenges me to like
be more engaged with the world I got to
know everything that's going on in news
in the world and but it's been fantastic
because it's it has made me become a
more well-rounded person I feel and
human being and understanding more about
how the world works and works and what
goes on in the world and it's
interesting and I I go into GMA with the
same kind of amusement and awe as I went
into a game
uh and and the football player like I
walk in I first I can't believe I'm
there
um and secondly I'm always curious as I
was in sport so it's a perfect fit for
what I've done in the past and what I'm
doing now in the present and then you
know you're branching out you're a mogul
you got the Michael Strahan apparel line
and now uh new skin products here that
uh available at CVS stores so it's all
working out yeah you know you know the
name of it Michael Strahan daily defense
wow man yeah baby yeah I I reached for
that one reach really deep but you know
what it is honestly it's um we had the
clothing brand and and and which is
organic to my life and what I do and
suits every day and then casual
athleisure when I'm not
um or or work Leisure if you want to
call it that and and then the skin care
because every day the grit and grime of
being on TV or just running around every
day and men don't have a routine men are
very much set in the belief that skin
care is something mostly that women do
or you just grab um somebody else's
products put them on and hide whatever
you have in the shelves but that's not
what we developed we developed something
that I use every day organic to me
um and it has a lot of properties like
activated silk that you only find in
like Chanel products very high-end
products and it is um a nice little
routine that we have for men that takes
about the same time it takes to brush
your teeth to give you good skin because
as we know you dress good you feel
confident if you got great skin that's
even more confident would you would you
well-rounded man cosmetic surgery would
you do Botox
oh I I don't need it buddy look at me
that's 50 year old skin right there
black don't crack but no no good blank
doesn't crack yeah you're right no you
know what what I do about time I never
thought about it I kind of like wrinkles
in my forehead if I got them you know
it's kind of I wanted you I want you to
see my expression
um
yeah who do p are you mistaken for
somebody like yeah like I've been
mistaken for so many people like who I
remember being at um the uh Baptist
Court Garden one time at a basketball
game and some guy walked all the way
down to the from up top and go hey
Riddick bow I'm like what ready bro I
should knock you out for calling me him
and have you sue Riddick both thinking
out with him like I've been called
Riddick but of course I get the Mike
Tyson because again
the list and the Gap in my teeth and
everything else
um wait you you were you would Tower
over you would be Lennox Lewis to Mike
Tyson thank you thank you but people
don't I guess they figure well they all
look short on TV or the same height on
TV I don't know but yeah I've been
called Mike Tyson Riddick bro
um I've been called in front of my fox
guys we were filming some promo in
California and some guy like hey and I'm
like yeah you know he knows me yeah and
I'm with Howie and Jimmy and Terry and
the guy go Michael and I'm like hey you
know he didn't say nothing to none of
you guys and then the guy runs up to us
afterwards and he's like hey man I just
want you to know that I was adopted too
by a white family and um
like I'm not Michael or
[Laughter]
The Blind Side and then all the guys
that I tell you I was like not in front
of them kid not in front of them
yeah my God my job is to get to the guy
that Michael Oher is trying to block
exactly but I'm glad you were inspired
by The Blind Side good luck to you but I
am not him I didn't I just said thank
you I didn't even tell him it wasn't me
I said thank you I appreciate it man and
um Good Luck yeah but you you know what
you can't top this I had somebody come
up and say man I listen to you every
morning on SportsCenter and I love when
you say booyah
they thought it was sure Scott God yeah
they thought you were stood what did
they have a they obviously they need to
do TV
but isolation is horrible I I signed the
autograph I'm thinking all right you
know people people still think I'm on
SportsCenter they'll go I watch on
SportsCenter every morning and I go all
right haven't been there in 16 years the
thing is but it's but it's a testament
to how what you did absolutely memorable
absolutely that people can't even get it
out of their mind and your voice is
Iconic yeah very lucky so you know and
that's why you've had the career man but
I look at it like this when at some
point No One's Gonna care No One's Gonna
even bother the ones you can walk into a
room nobody even but yeah and so I
always try to make sure that I tell
myself you are not you are not what you
do
so don't get so thought bit twisted to
think that if you're not recognized for
your job that it means you have no value
because at some point
you probably won't be and that's when it
becomes dangerous so for me I just try
to keep that in mind because at one
point all of this stuff and goes away
and you know what do you have left in
that outside of just enjoying your life
and your family so that's what I'm
trying to hang on to yeah you got your
daughters when it's all said and done
yeah yeah I got those twins teenagers
high schools seniors boyfriends
as Barkley said if you kill the first
guy who comes over word will get around
then you don't have to worry about the
next guy coming over to date your
daughters well uh Holly gave me a great
one at a friend of his said
um to one of the one of the boys who
said I just want you to know I'll do the
tie
[Laughter]
it's great
I could just see Howie you know very you
know hey I'm willing to do the time I'm
willing to do the tide so go ahead try
it I know you're busy always great to
spend some time with you Michael thanks
for joining us good luck all right we
gotta do this more often man miss you
thank you Michael Strahan Michael
Strahan apparel available at Men's
Warehouse in the new skin and shave line
Michael Strahan daily defense available
at CVS take a break back after this